If you could somehow look into the future and you found out that two years from now,...
...you would develop a disease that would confine you to a hospital bed until the day you died,...
...would you change anything about the way you're living your life right now?
Have you ever stopped and asked yourself if you're truly living each day to the fullest?
Or are you letting your life pass you by?
My name is Duane and I'd say I have a pretty good life.
I've got a fun career doing something that I really enjoy.
I'm young and in good health.
And I've got some great friends and family.
But recent events have caused me to ask myself if I've truly been making the most of my life.
And one of the biggest things I've realized is that I've been so wrapped up in the pursuit of material wealth and building my career,...
...but I haven't taken many opportunities to sit back and appreciate the world around me.
I've let the fear of being unsuccessful get in the way of doing many of the things that I've always wanted to do.
So, I figured it's time to make a change.
I've come up with a concept of reset, live, and grow.
I'm gonna start by completely resetting my approach to life and reevaluating how I spend my time.
Then, I'm gonna do my best to live in the present moment and challenge myself to try new things that I was too afraid to do in the past.
And I think ultimately these things are gonna help me grow into a bigger person.
So, I've decided to put my career on pause...
...to travel the world and gain a new perspective on life.
It's sort of like a mini retirement.
I'm gonna take my video camera with me to document the whole process...
...as I experience all kinds of new things in various countries around the world.
This is gonna be a huge journey for me and I'm making a big sacrifice to do it but in the end I know it's gonna be worth it.
So if you wanna come along for the ride, press this 'subscribe' button on this Youtube channel and stay tuned.